vielen dank jeanette klag und ganz kurz
der hinweis später wird hier im studio
alfred schier übernehmen wir bleiben
jetzt weiter im live-programm bei
phoenix und wir haben natürlich nur ein
thema und jetzt in der internationalen
phoenix runde mit alexander keller
wie oft reden wir von zäsur wenn es
eigentlich nur ein zettelchen ist aber
was seit donnerstag in und um die
ukraine passiert ist eine gewaltige
zäsur über jahrzehnte aufgebaute und
gehegte politische überzeugungen
missionen und sehnsüchte haben sich als
illusion erwiesen als geplatzte reifen
lassen vieles muss ganz neu gedacht
werden und nicht nur die ukraine zittert
vor dem gewalt fanatiker wladimir putin
möglicherweise ist sein ziel die
unterwerfung ganz europas also muss
gehandelt werden in alle richtungen und
verdammt schnell der freie europa muss
sich schützen gerade militärisch und den
gefährlichsten störenfried weltweit ins
visier nehmen kriegen europa wie schaut
die welt auf putin jetzt in der
internationalen phoenix runde
phoenix runde
ich danke allen die in diesen tagen
zeichen setzen gegen putins krieg und
die sich hier in berlin und anderswo zu
friedlichen kundgebungen versammeln
und ich danke allen die in diesen zeiten
mit uns einstehen für ein freies und
offenes gerechtes und friedliches europa
wir werden es verteidigen
herr putin auch sie sind und waren von
der nato nie bedroht das wissen sie auch
das wissen sie auch
die einzige bedrohung
dies führt ihn und seinen nomenklatura
die einzige bedrohung und die nimmt er
zu recht sehr ernst ist die bedrohung
seiner macht durch das eigene volk die
bedrohung durch freiheit und demokratie
auch in seiner nachbarschaft da ist die
bedrohung für dieses system
so weit der bundeskanzler und der
oppositionsführer heute an diesem
denkwürdigen tag im parlament und damit
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio sind monika
priesmeier tkotsch sie sind
stellvertretende direktorin der
europäischen akademie berlin
beschäftigen sich vor allen dingen mit
osteuropa und im besonderen der ukraine
ist doch von marschall ist bei uns
diplomatische korrespondent der
chefredaktion der zeitung tagesspiegel
auch hier aus berlin und zugeschaltet
aus
washington die ard-korrespondentin
verena güntner und
zugeschaltet ebenfalls unser kollege
andrej kurkow
redakteurin der russischen redaktion der
deutschen welle
wir haben drei stunden über drei stunden
jetzt fast eigentlich fast vier stunden
bundestag
übertragen
welchen eindruck hat dass auf sie
gemacht der ukrainische botschafter war
ja auch die ganze zeit anwesend gewesen
war das ein deutliches ein klares signal
es ist der nicht nur das klare signal
dass der ukrainische botschafter mailen
liegt da war dass wir tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende erleben sondern man konnte
das natürlich sehr gut hören sowohl von
den beiträgen des bundeskanzlers scholz
als auch natürlich von den anderen
mitgliedern der regierungskoalition aber
auch teilweise der opposition das seit
einigen tagen erleben wir etwas in
europa was was wir bisher so nicht
wahrnehmen wollten und wo wir uns neu
justieren müssen
verändern müssen und diese veränderungen
natürlich auch umfassende auswirkungen
auf unser leben auf unsere wirtschaft
aber auch natürlich erst unser
verständnis der welt haben doch da hat
man heute im bundestag äußerungen gehört
die vor einer woche eigentlich noch fast
undenkbar gewesen wären von den
abgeordneten die sie gemacht haben heute
wie schätzen sie das ein was hat der
bundestag damit eigentlich ausdrücken
wollen was hat er tatsächlich
ausgedrückt richtung ukraine aber eben
auch richtung russland
ich habe natürlich als russe besonders
aufmerksam die signale nach russland
gehört und für mich ist es tragisch aber
völlig nachvollziehbar und völlig
richtig dass man davon spricht dass die
einstellung der europäer der deutschen
zu russland sie grundsätzlich verändert
hat und man alles neu bewerten muss was
in den letzten jahren oder jahrzehnten
in den europäisch russischen
deutsch-russischen beziehungen passiert
ich war immer ein brückenbauer
journalist hat mich immer so verstanden
aber jetzt
ist für mich klar viele brücken sind
zerstört und an einigen brücken sollten
wir gar nicht erst wieder aufbauen damit
bildlich gesprochen über diese brücken
keine neuen panzer fahren und mancher
der bundestag
hat debattiert nach einer
regierungserklärung das war auch
dringend notwendig für deutschland sich
zu positionieren
im
krieg gegen die ukraine dem russischen
krieg gegen die ukraine da gab es ja
durchaus sehr disparate und fast
kakophonischen äußerungen letzten tagen
und wochen ist ihm dem bundestag in
dieser gesamten
repräsentation heute es gelungen zu
sagen deutschland hat sich jetzt klar
gemacht wo stehen wir und wie wollen wir
jetzt diesen konflikt der inzwischen
längst ein krieg ist auch lösen helfen
ist eine katastrophale situation aber in
dem sinne wie sie gefragt haben hat die
bundesregierung der bundestag sich jetzt
endlich richtig positioniert ja in
diesem sinne war es ein guter tag
deutschland hat sehr sehr lange
gebraucht bis es sozusagen mitten im
europäischen verbund steht mitten im
transatlantischen verbund steht
die partner haben auf uns geschaut als
die schwächste kette im glied als die
unsicheren kantonisten die lange nicht
mal die pipeline nord stream 2 aufgeben
wollten die schon seit jahren nicht
bereit sind ihren verteidigungs beitrag
zu leisten und in diesem sinne war der
bundeskanzler heute sehr sehr klar ja
wir werden zwei hat sogar gesagt mehr
als die zwei prozent für verteidigung
ausgeben müssen es ist völlig klar dass
wir uns nun auch an den boykott des
zahlungssystems beteiligen wollen trifft
auch wenn es ein bisschen differenziert
ist damit nach dem ihr putin nicht
weiter die euros und die dollar dollars
bekommt hätte er seine kriegsmaschinerie
schmiert also in diesem sinne fast durch
alle fraktionen mit ausnahme von teil
der afd und der linken haben wir die
nötige klare distanz distanzierung von
putin erlebt aber es war eine späte
reaktion der deutschen politik bis sie
endlich zum richtigen standpunkt fand
verbünden die deutschen als unsichere
kantonisten das geht in washington
wahrscheinlich realisieren leicht über
die lippen als die bundestagsdebatte
heute begann mit der regierungserklärung
war es in washington noch
nachtschlafender zeit aber in den
letzten 24 stunden hat sich in der
deutschen politik eine menge getan
verschärfte sanktionen jetzt soll auch
swift dieser zahlung dieses
zahlungsverkehrssystem mit einbezogen
werden in die sanktionen in deutschland
ist bereits sowohl direkt als auch
indirekt waffen zu liefern
so in die ukraine in ein kriegsgebiet
was bislang undenkbar hat man das in
washington eigentlich schon registriert
diese doch ziemlich starke wendung der
fast 180 grad drehung hier in berlin und
in deutschland
diese kurswende wurde auf jeden fall
registrierte in washington denn
deutschland stand ja auch unter
besonderer beobachtung und auch durchaus
lange zeit sehr kritische beobachtung
der tiefpunkt waren da sicherlich die
lieferung der 5000 helme danach so ist
inzwischen bekannt geworden musste die
deutsche botschafterin hier sogar einen
brandbrief nach berlin schreiben um
nochmal aufzuklären wie irritiert die
amerikaner eigentlich waren und dann kam
ja auch olaf scholz und kanzler besuch
und konnte da die stimmung wieder ein
wenig drehen zumindest ist mir
aufgefallen dass die medien danach
wieder etwas freundlicher auf
deutschland schauten so kann man davon
ausgehen dass jetzt eben dieser
kurswechsel sehr begrüßt wird ich habe
heute morgen in den medien gehört dass
da jemand sagte germany has joined
befreit also deutschland kämpft jetzt
mit was eben auch zeigt dass wir vorher
hauptsächlich als die bremser gesehen
wurden zumindest von den kritischen
medien burghof lassen sie uns als erstes
mal auf russland sehen wir kennen die
bilder und die reaktionen die schlimmen
bilder aus der ukraine auch reaktionen
im westen nicht nur die
bundestagssitzung es gab viele
äußerungen vieler politiker im gesamten
nato bereich auch darüber hinaus was wir
relativ wenig wissen was ist eigentlich
gerade in russland los wir sind putin
gerade eben noch mal mit der ankündigung
die
atomwaffen jetzt sozusagen in der die
atomwaffen verbände in alarmbereitschaft
zu versetzen wir sehen handlauf und wir
sehen verängstigte menschen in der
fußgängerzone die kaum bereits in
interviews zu geben wir sehen
verhaftungen was ist im moment in
russland los wie reagieren die menschen
bekommen sie das überhaupt mit was
gerade passiert
also was erfreulich ist dass die zahl
derer die sich gegen diesen krieg
gewarnt haben doch größer ist als man in
dieser situation vermuten könnte wir
haben demonstrationen gesehen von 100
menschen nicht von 100.000 t in berlin
aber von hunderten menschen in moskau
und sankt petersburg nva also in
verschiedenen anderen städten wir haben
mehrere petitionen oder briefe
unterschrieben von
wissenschaftlern von ärzten und
krankenschwestern von künstlern es haben
sich sportler zu wort gemeldet ich würde
aber diese reaktion fordert sich nicht
überbewerten ein großer teil der
bevölkerung dürften stocks klar sein
eventuell wird sich das morgen ändern
nachdem all diese sanktionen die gerade
jetzt am samstag und am heutigen sonntag
verkündet worden sind zu allen zu
schweren wirtschaftlichen verwerfungen
kommen werden also zum verfall des rubel
kurses möglicherweise zur schließung der
börse möglicherweise zu problemen beim
bargeld bei der bargeldabhebung aber das
größte und wichtigste problem ist seit
jahren wurde in russland eine massive
staatliche propaganda geführt gerade
gegen die ukraine in richtung ukraine
die einen regelrechten hass gegen die
ukraine und die gegen die ukraine in der
russischen bevölkerung
hervorgebracht hat neben dem hass den
man ohnehin schon gegenüber den westen
empfindet vor allem dingen gegenüber den
usa da teilt sich das so auch die usa
werden gehasst europa wird verachtet und
das sitzt dieses narrativ sitzt in
vielen köpfen drin deswegen das ist
schwierig zu beurteilen inwieweit die
menschen das verinnerlicht haben
künstler haben sich das wort gemeldet in
russland ein künstler hat sich auch zu
wort gemeldet der in seinem früheren
leben comedian war nämlich der jetzige
präsident der ukraine talents geht er ja
auch in russland aufgetreten ist früher
perfekt russisch spricht er hat sich
zweimal glaube ich jetzt direkt an das
russische volk gewendet wenn man jetzt
das hört was alexander etwas an der
grund- kopf aus russland berichtet hat
welche welche möglichkeit hat dann die
ukraine selbst in form von einzel ins
gesicht direkt an das russische volk zu
wenden hilft das auf jeden fall also es
ist auf jeden fall es ist so wir müssen
das mal deutlich sagen es herrscht krieg
in europa und es ist keine
friedensmission es ist keine
militärische auseinandersetzung zwischen
zwei ländern es ist ein krieg und das
schlimme ist es ist tatsächlich auch ein
krieg zwischen
eigentlich zwei brüder volker 2 zwischen
miteinander sehr eng verbundenen
nationen und das ist grauenvoll und das
ist ja auch wichtig zu sagen es ist ein
krieg nicht russland gegen die ukraine
sondern das ist ein krieg putin schon
regina regime gegenüber salewski oder
gegenüber die ukraine und das was gerade
sein institut und ich würde sagen das
ist auch ein zeichen wie heutzutage auch
die kriegsführung funktioniert das ist
ja es wird nicht nur mit waffen
ausgetragen nicht nur mit panzern
sondern es wird natürlich auch im
digitalen raum ausgetragen
desinformation spielt eine enorme rolle
aber auch natürlich die zu übertragen
und das was gerade sie längst versucht
der jacke sprüngli tatsächlich und das
haben sich auch gesagt russisch spricht
der hat vor seiner präsidentschaft sehr
schnell ukrainisch gelernt er kommt aber
aus der russischsprachigen teile ukraine
er versucht diese brücken zu bauen daher
versuchte deutlich zu machen dass das
was gerade passiert ist eine ein grollen
tat was man in diesen regionen von
europa seit lange nicht mehr gesehen hat
und dann versucht natürlich damit auch
die die russische bevölkerung zu
erreichen und es wird übrigens auch
dieser versuch an die menschen in
russland zu kommen das wird natürlich
auch aus europa gemacht über
verschiedene kanäle über all das was in
den menschen den gesellschaften und auch
den organisierten gruppen zur verfügung
steht all das was wir im digitalen raum
zur verfügung haben ganz kurz mal zurück
zum verkauf
putin hat ja selensky als
drogenabhängigen neo nazi bezeichnet
diese form der diffamierung der
niederträchtigen herabwürdigung verfängt
die in russland sie haben gerade
gesprochen dass natürlich die russische
bevölkerung dieser propaganda moment
relativ schutzlos ausgesetzt ist
ja das verfängt und das ist vielleicht
mit das tragische für chile so vermute
ich dass zumindest wir dürfen ja den
meinungsumfragen kein besonderes
vertrauen schenken aber für viele ist
die argumentation des kremls in russland
nachvollziehbar oder sie stehen dahinter
also dass der zielsatz dass es osten der
ukraine ein genozid gegeben habe oder
der angeblich immer noch läuft also mord
an massenmord an russen und die
verteidigt werden müssen dass da
tatsächlich die macht an sich in der
ukraine
faschisten mit dem wort falsch ist kann
man sehr schnell große emotionen
hochkochen lassen das also in der
faschisten an der macht sind die man nun
beseitigen müsse das klingt alles
absolut wild und absurd hier in europa
das kommt aber in russland bei sehr
vielen besonders bei denen die das
fernsehen konsumieren oder nur das
fernsehen konsumieren noch nicht denn
das internet reinschauen das kommt gut
an deswegen würde ich die unterstützung
für putin in den breiten
bevölkerungsschichten nicht
unterschätzen was nicht heißt dass
sobald die menschen materielle nachteile
in ihren täglichen leben zu spüren
bekommen dass sich ihre stimmung ändert
aber ich glaube dass zum jetzigen tag
kann sich putin das muss ich mit großem
herzblut bestehen einer ziemlich breiten
unterstützung der bevölkerung sicher
sein lassen es kurz auf die deutsche
innenpolitik noch mal sehen was wir
heute im bundestag gehört haben jetzt
kurz angedeutet dass waren äußeren und
die vor einer woche noch undenkbar
gewesen während das heißt das war seine
art massenhaftes
damaskus erlebnis neuen testament wo
dann mit einer 180 grad wendung aus dem
saulus paulus wird ist das denn was da
in der deutschen innenpolitik in den
letzten tagen passiert ist es das
glaubhaft glaubwürdig hält das durch
oder ist das aus ihrer sicht nur
deswegen im moment so
engagiert so überzeugt weil man sich der
gefährlichkeit der situation bewusst ist
es ist eine mischung aus beidem aber ich
bin ehrlich gesagt doch ziemlich
optimistisch dass dieser schock er zu
tief sitzen ganz haben mehrere wichtige
politiker der regierung erklärt dass sie
das nicht für möglich gehalten haben
dass er jetzt aufgewacht sind haben sich
dazu bekannt dass sie über jahre die
situation und den menschen die mir putin
falsch eingeschätzt haben und wenn der
bundeskanzler aus der spd auf einmal
sagt ja wir werden jetzt nicht nur
richtung zwei prozent sondern ab sofort
mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für verteidigung
ausgeben wenn die grünen die bis vor
wenigen tagen
noch gesagt haben keine waffen an die
ukraine auf einmal sagen ja wir müssen
warten an die ukraine liefern das sind
so viele kehrtwenden auch im
schriftsystem ich meine noch vor zwei
tagen war die bundes außenministerin
annalena baerbock im fernsehen und hat
erklärt warum wir uns nicht an einen
ausschluss russlands aus dem
zahlungssystem beteiligen können weil
das deutschland härter treffen würde als
russland und jetzt auf einmal die
einfach gesagt seine finanzpolitische
oder fiskalische atombombe auch er hat
natürlich ist es besonders wichtig dass
es in der bundesregierung passiert denn
die bundesregierung in ihrer parteien
haben die mehrheit und jetzt haben wir
sozusagen eine kleine weisheit der
geschichte es ist ja gerade gut dass in
diesem moment die sozialdemokraten und
die grünen mit der fdp an der regierung
sind weil sie selber jetzt gezwungen
sind zu handeln und den kurs zu
korrigieren
hätten wir im moment eine
cdu/csu/fdp-regierung dann wäre es für
eine opposition aus sozialdemokraten und
grünen soll ich mal sagen die wären
stärker in versuchung an ihren alten
wahrheiten festzuhalten und den schwenk
nicht nur zu machen gerade weil es rot
grün ist das ist ja ähnlich wie vor
vielen jahren im kosovo krieg das ist ja
ironischerweise eine rot grüne
bundesregierung war die deutschland zum
ersten mal nach dem krieg wieder in eine
kampfsituation geführt hat und so etwas
ähnliches passiert rein psychologisch
betrachtet im moment es ist gut dass die
sozialdemokraten mit den grünen diesen
kurskorrektur in dieser schärfe
vornehmen sie werden dabei auch
unterstützt von der größten
oppositionspartei der union und insofern
habe ich doch die hoffnung dass das
nachhaltig ist und nicht nur dem moment
geschuldet sie sind ja als
diplomatischer dürftig dürfte
kurz daran ja
dürfte ich kurz daran erinnern dass die
grünen von allen parteien die
konsequentesten
unterstützer der ukraine seit jahren
waren und die härtesten kritiker und
gegner putins das sollte man nicht
vergessen
wollte ich einfach nur in die runde
geworfen haben weil viele viele parteien
ganz abgesehen von der afg und den
linken die sehr oft gut im kurs waren
viele parteien haben sich in der oder
jenem vom
sozialen annäherungsversuch an putin
erlaubt mehr als es glaube ich nötig war
die einzige partei das ist jetzt keine
parteiwerbung aber einfach mal eine
feststellung waren die grün und kabel
kann schon voriges jahr nach dem besuch
des donners gesagt man müsse an
verteidigungswaffen an lieferungen an
die ukraine denken und wurde sehr hart
kritisiert in der deutschen
öffentlichkeit
ich wollte das nur einmal klargestellt
ist dass das ist völlig richtig da kann
ich sie nur unterstützen es waren aber
nicht nur die grünen so dass zum
beispiel gegen nord stream haben wir
bereits seit 23 jahren vor allem grün
schwarze unterschriftenlisten
garantierte man wenig von den
sozialdemokraten und die liberalen aber
ein teil der cdu hat durchaus auch
opponiert gegen diese russland-politik
die routinen unterschätzt hat aber was
sie noch mal hervorheben dass gerade in
der grünen partei die skepsis gegenüber
wladimir putin die unterstützung der
russischen und der ukrainischen anti
putin opposition besonders groß war das
unterstreiche ich auch immer wenn ich
mit meinen freunden in ostmitteleuropa
also in polen in ungarn zweiter rede die
er zum teil große besorgnis haben das
angeblich die grünen zu friedens bewegt
sein und die gefahren nicht sehen also
den punkt kann ich nur unterstützen aber
sie hatten habe ich noch eine andere
frage die kleinen nach wollen frau
gründen kurz an sprechen diese an starre
die sich jetzt im westen bereit gemacht
hat durch diesen russischen überfall auf
die ukraine hat ja wieder gezeigt wie
wichtig eben der zusammenhalt in der
nato mit der stärksten macht an der
spitze den usa sind das was joe biden
den letzten tagen da gesagt hat die
reaktion aus den usa hat man da auch den
ernst der lage erkannt oder ist die
ukraine mit 8000 kilometer luftlinie
doch ziemlich weit weg
also was das weiße haus angeht da hat
man den ernst der lage auf jeden fall
erkrankt das ist auch ein thema also
sein konflikt in sicht erst mal
sicherlich nicht gewünscht hat in er
lenkt ihn von seinen eigentlichen
prioritäten ab aber dieser system kampf
demokratie schützen und verteidigen
gegen die aufstrebenden autokratien das
ist ja etwas was er sich von anfang an
als aufgabe gegeben hat also da ist er
sehr entschieden und er ist ja eben auch
ein überzeugter transatlantiker anders
als sein vorgänger also ist es durchaus
in beiden interesse die nato wieder zu
stärken und sie eben nicht zu schwächen
trotzdem hat joe biden das problem dass
er sich in einem wahljahr befindet wir
haben im herbst kongresswahlen und er
muss natürlich sehr genau schauen wie
viel das amerikanische volk auch bereit
ist mit zu tragen
ist es ganz klar dass man nicht bereit
ist einen militärischen einsatz mit zu
tragen und die große frage ist was ist
mit preissteigerungen was ist mit
inflation auch da gibt es einiges was
ihnen politisch heikel werden könnte für
beiden in diesem wahljahr und ja in
diesem dilemma in dieser dieser spanne
bewegen er sich also wir haben ja mit
trump vier jahre ausnahmesituationen usa
die usa ist ein stück weit zurück
gekehrt zu ihrem sonst bekannten
politikstil durchzuarbeiten aber zum
ersten mal fällt aus er fällt auf dass
bei einer außenpolitischen bedrohung die
auch die usa irgendwie trifft die
innenpolitischen differenzen nicht nur
nicht beseitigt werden sondern sogar
noch instrumentalisiert werden für diese
außenpolitischen diskussionen wie
gefährlich ist das nicht nur für joe
biden sondern auch letztendlich für uns
was zum beispiel rechte republikaner
jetzt in den usa an diskussionen da vom
zaun gebrochen haben können wir uns auf
die usa wirklich noch hundertprozentig
verlassen
also joe biden steht so im wort dass man
sich denke ich mal erst mal auf ihn
verlassen kann aber es ist in der tat
für ihn eine schwierige lage also wenn
man es jetzt mal die republikaner
angucken die sich normalerweise in so
einem fall hinter dem präsidenten jahren
würden das eben war gerade drei
verschiedene strömungen
wir sehen als extremste
trump und seine gefolgsleute die
trappisten die ja immer noch sehr
freundliche worte für putin finden die
am liebsten sehen würden dass beiden
sich ausschließlich mit innenpolitik und
mit der süd grenze zu mexiko befasst
dann haben wir die strömung unter den
republikanern die sagen ja gut also wir
müssen jetzt gegen russland handeln aber
möglichst nicht so lange und intensiv
den unser eigentlicher feind der ist
doch china und dann gibt es noch die
republikaner vermeiden schlagen so er
die traditionellen falken die sind
derzeit im senat noch gut vertreten und
die wollen scharfe sanktionen und
haltens mit reagans alter doktrin aus
dem kalten krieg frieden durch stärke
aber auch da also der den die
bereitschaft zu einem militärischen
einsatz da würde ich ein großes großes
fragezeichen dran machen und dann am
anderem auch deswegen weil joe biden ja
auch gesagt hat wenn wir uns gegen die
russen stellen auf einem schlachtfeld
dann löst das womöglich den dritten
weltkrieg aus gleichzeitig ist aber
dennoch im wort er hat auch gesagt wenn
es um die nato-partner geht dann wird
jeder zentimeter verteidigt also das ist
jetzt ja auch wieder einen ein
spannungsfeld wo wir beobachten müssen
wie die usa sich dann weiter verarbeiten
da auch den rückhalt in der bevölkerung
das ist ja ganz wichtig bei dem was sie
zum schluss an gesprochen haben falls es
doch zu einer militärischen eskalation
an der ostgrenze
der nato in europa kommt
also beiden hat nicht den rückhalt für
soldaten auf ukrainischem boden da ist
ja auch immer ganz klar natürlich sind
die amerikaner gerade bewegt von den
bildern sie fühlen mit den ukrainern der
ukrainische präsident imponiert ihnen
also die amerikaner haben wir ein herz
für helden aber das geht eben nicht so
weit dass man bereit ist alles
mitzutragen und selbst was den nato
einsatz angeht gibt es da auch um fragen
das dann noch keine mehrheit der
amerikaner vollkommen hinter einem
einsatz stehen würde das ist aber jetzt
wahrscheinlich einfach noch zu früh hier
in den usa versucht man ja von der
strategie es erstmal auf abschreckung zu
setzen also ich denke dass wir haben ja
die 7000 soldaten gesehen die nach
deutschland geschickt werden um auch von
dort aus die nato aus planke weiter zu
verstärken es wird jetzt erst mal denke
ich in richtung abschreckungspolitik
gehen bevor sich dann die frage nach der
letztendlich ein solidarität stellt
erstmalig an lasst uns also noch einen
moment auf der weinebene bleiben als
diplomatische chefkorrespondent haben
sie ja mit diesen themen auch zu tun wie
ist es eigentlich um die solidarität der
völkergemeinschaft gestellt vorgestern
im un sicherheitsrat gab es ein veto der
russen es gab aber auch drei
enthaltungen
von indien von china und den vereinigten
arabischen in den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten
ist die wie sieht der rest der welt auf
diesen konflikt und wie verhält er sich
also der großteil der großteil der welt
steht eindeutig emotional auf der seite
der ukraine der bruch des völkerrechts
die schuldfrage das ist alles zu
eindeutig meine auch dass putin diese
rede gehalten hat vorher in der
behauptet es gebe überhaupt keine
ukrainischen nationen und es gebe auch
keinen ukrainischen zu bereden staat das
sei im prinzip so und und erfolg der
russin die dazu historisch sozusagen
verdammt seien von den russen regiert zu
werden weil sonst chaos ausbricht sie
können sich gar nicht selber regieren
und dann dieser angriffe oft viele haben
ja gedacht na ja der putin übt druck aus
oder es geht ihm nur um die ost ukraine
um die russischsprachigen gebiete und
diese ganzen lügen propagandalügen von
genozid über selbstbestimmungsrecht das
hier angeblich greife das glaubt ihm ja
alles kann niemand aber dass er dann
auch noch von mehreren seiten die
ukraine flächendeckend an greift ja
umzingelt es nicht nicht nicht die nato
und russland sondern russland hat die
ukraine umzingelt von mehreren seiten
und greift von mehreren seiten an das
glaube ich hat die situation geklärt es
gibt keine sympathien für putin der ist
völlig isoliert die frage ist jetzt ja
gut aber was heißt das wie verhält man
sich und sie sehen es eben an china
china ist auf der einen seite natürlich
dagegen dass die nato sich noch nach
weiter nach osten erweitert das war zu
beginn der olympischen spiele klar
damals haben china und russland eine
gemeinsame erklärung gegen ost
erweiterung die ja gar nicht zur debatte
steht im moment unterzeichnet aber als
der angriff kam haben die chinesen sich
gegen die aggression gegen die ukraine
gestellt aber im weltsicherheitsrat sich
dann wieder neutral falten also das ist
so ein kittel spiel china möchte weder
den eindruck erwecken dass putins
aggression unterstützt aber es wird
natürlich auch nicht dass die besten die
situation dazu nutzt sich straße zu
starten und das russland geholfen das
hat sich ja in einigen regionen
außerhalb europas breitgemacht afrika
naher osten
er hilft das der russischen strategie in
diesem speziellen fall na ja teils teils
nicht also schauen wir uns mal so ein
fall wie syrien an natürlich wirkt da
russland unheimlich stark barack obama
damalige us präsident hat sich als
giftgas eingesetzt wurde nicht
entscheiden können obwohl er vor da die
rote linie gezogen hatte zu reagieren
wladimir putin geht da rein aber dann
sehen alle was für einen krieg dieser
wladimir putin vierter werden all app
oder werden großstädte bombardiert ohne
rücksicht auf die zivilbevölkerung
dasselbe passiert ja jetzt wieder nicht
ganz so krass aber wir alle haben doch
die bilder vom beschuss von wohnhäusern
in kiew gesehen wir sehen das zum teil
lager für radioaktiven müll beschossen
werden es ist ja völlig
verantwortungslos wie dieser putin mit
seiner armee das führt also deswegen ich
glaube ich kann nicht sehen dass über
die letzten jahre wladimir putin mit
seiner art politik zu machen sympathien
gewonnen hat das eigentlich genau das
gegenteil ist so ein mephisto verlust er
ist derjenige der immer das gegenteil
von dem erreicht was er möchte er
behauptet er möchte die ukraine dafür
gewinnen dass man eine gemeinsame
wirtschafts union macht was glauben sie
welche ukrainer noch gerne mit putin in
einer in einer wirtschaftsunion leben
möchte er sagt die ganze zeit er möchte
verhindern dass es mehr nato soldaten an
der ostgrenze gibt na was macht man bei
so einem angriff man stellt natürlich
mehr nato soldaten an die ostgrenze
damit das baltikum geschützt ist was ja
sowieso ein sehr schwieriger punkt ist
also es sind mehrere beispiele putin
erklärt ziele und erreicht immer genau
das gegenteil von dem was er möchte mit
dem was er tut und sympathien gewinnt so
gewiss nicht
gestern ist der polnische
ministerpräsident in berlin gewesen und
hat sich sagen als visitenkarte gleich
einem massiven angriff auf deutschland
gestartet er deutschland steinernen
egoismus vorgeworfen in der ukraine
wiese da reibt man sich bei polen
insofern etwas die augen weil vor der
ukraine krise vor dem ukraine krieg man
ja eigentlich was mir das gefühl hatte
dass polen nur sich im auge hat und die
europäischen verträge dies
unterschrieben hat eigentlich nicht
besonders ernst nimmt jetzt lässt es
sich in proeuropäischen
verhalten gar nicht mehr übertreffen
polen auch ungarn übrigens
ist das ist dass die nackte angst was
steckt genau dahinter hat man oder hat
man gemerkt dass man auf dem holzweg ist
nee ich glaube man muss tatsächlich die
beiden sachen voneinander trennen einmal
die rechtsstaatlichkeit debatte die es
ja gibt und die es nach wie vor geben
wird und das andere ist ja thema
stabilität sicherheit aber auch
natürlich die die entwicklungen in der
region und dann die polen nehmen das
glaube ich sehr sehr war möchtest du
einen frieden bereitest du dich auf den
krieg vor das ist nämlich ein sehr gutes
altes sprichwort das sagt okay wir
können frieden in europa mit einem
despoten wie putin nicht haben wenn wir
einfach nur mit wirtschaftlichen
austausch und mit gesprächen dass
vertrieben deswegen die polnische
regierung hat das tatsächlich auch schon
seit langem darauf hingewiesen dass das
was im osten passiert auch die ganze
rhetorik von puten auch natürlich die
entwicklungen im osten sei
besorgniserregend sind sie haben das
auch gesehen dass die flüchtlingswelle
die ist jahren der belarussischen
college-spieler russischen und
litauischen grenze gab ein teil von
dieser strategie ist und polen hat
tatsächlich auch relativ früh nämlich
anfang januar wenn nicht schon im
letzten jahr die unterstützung der
ukraine zugesetzt das heißt es war
deutlich es wird diese anlage wird
eskalieren dass es so schnell kommt dass
es so
dynamisch wird dass es so
tragisch wird man konnte man nicht
absehen aber das ist verständnis und das
ist ja auch etwas was dieses verständnis
dass die schicksale von den beiden
von ost und west miteinander verbunden
sind und das wäre einfach mal ukraine
als teil von europa wahrnehmen müssen
egal ob sie in der europäischen union
sind oder nicht das sind sehr stark in
der polnischen ostpolitik verankert die
übrigens natürlich auch sehr lange
tradition hat und die sich auch über
über die jahrzehnte sehr stark
entwickelt hat letzter satz zurzeit
macht sehr macht sich ein zitat von der
kaczynskis breit
aus tiflis von 2008
als ist ja dem georgisch russischen
krieg gab da ist lech kaczynski
leider jahr 2010 in smolensk und
gekommen ist hat deutlich gemacht
gegenüber den georgischen volk heute
georgien morgen ukraine übermorgen
baltische staaten und dann irgendwann
vielleicht wir und ich glaube dieses
verständnis für die komplexität der lage
in der region aber auch für die
gefälligkeit vom system putin den mann
überhaupt nicht trauen kann und diese
erinnerungen wie es ist in einem
sowjetischen blog zu sein und was ist
was man machen kann mit einer
autoritären macht das ist in der
polnischen politik sowohl in der
opposition als auch in der
regierungsmacht verankert und das kommt
jetzt zur geltung man hat aber das
gefühl dass zumindest in ungarn das gar
nicht mehr so in erinnerung ist was es
bedeutet und sowjetimperiums zu leben
orban hatte im letzten jahr glaube ich
gesagt ich versuche jetzt mal auf dem
gedächtnis zu zitieren bezug auf 956 den
volksaufstand die gefahr für ungarn
kommt ja gar nicht mehr aus moskau
sondern aus brüssel also von der eu
bürokratie
verschiebt sich auch da in der hinsicht
etwa ja auf jeden fall also orban hat ja
auch
abgesehen davon dass man vorgeschlagen
hat friedensgespräche zu führen
ist auch als angesehen das natürlich mal
die zustimmung zu dem swift
auf jeden fall erfolgen muss auf der
europäischen ebene sie haben absolut
recht die aufnahme der geflüchteten ist
ein bisschen anders in ungarn als in
polen also in polen hat eine
uneingeschränkte solidarität mit den
geflüchteten menschen erklärt da wird
über die bürokratischen hürden wird
geschaut hauptsache die menschen kommen
rein und
können hier in polen in sicherheit seien
bei orban ist es die lage ein bisschen
komplexer es hängt aber auch ein
bisschen mit wels balkan zu tun und
natürlich mit dem konzert der großmächte
auf dem westbalkan dass man auch mit
berücksichtigen will wenn man über die
ost west konflikt spricht insgesamt in
europa gibt so zumindest ein russisches
land namens serbien ich mitglied in der
eu nicht mitglied in der nato aber immer
die russische position vertreten
haben wir sozusagen denn jetzt mal
europa oder mittel und westeuropas ihn
quasi friendly fire im rücken wir hatten
das bis zu dieser eskalation aber ich
glaube schon dass der schock über die
eskalation und die qualität dieser
eskalation sehr viele regierungen auch
völker zum nachdenken bringt wo man
überhaupt noch sicherheit hat worauf man
sich noch verlassen kann und das ist ja
das entscheidende ich meinen in der nato
in der eu wir haben verbündete russland
hat ja keine verbündeten china hat keine
verbündeten und das ist manchmal etwas
schwierig sich dann zu verständigen
welche sanktionen und soweit das dauert
zeit ist man ein bündnis zusammen führt
dass alle dieselbe meinung haben aber
putin hat sehr viel dazu beigetragen
dass europa jetzt geschlossene
zusammensteht aber gelöst ist das
natürlich noch nicht veronika pries man
hat ja schon das baltikum angesprochen
das ist der nächste test punkt und ich
glaube wir müssen ist wirklich ernst
nehme ich möchte unseren zuschauern
nicht das thema domino-theorie die lech
kaczynski der frühere polnische
präsident damals 2008 von sich gegeben
hat dies könnte durchaus passieren also
erst georgien ukraine ja halt die kumpel
hat das leider müssen wir uns diese
sorgen machen das hat eben auch damit zu
tun dass die das baltic kommen die 3
kleinen staaten sind sehr schwer zu
verteidigen das hat auch was mit der
geografie zu tun weil der russland von
beiden seiten angreifen kann es gibt ja
die russische enklave in kaliningrad dem
östlichen dem früheren königs grad
königsberg das liegt westlich von den
baltischen staaten und putins truppen
sind velaros das ist köstlich der
baltischen staaten und ist ein sehr
schmaler korridor das heißt der zu weit
korridor der ist gerade mal 60 70
kilometer breit und wer in russland den
einnimmt von beiden seiten einer
zangenbewegung dann ist es sehr sehr
schwer für die nato das gebiet zu
verteidigen und da kommen wir wieder zu
der bedeutung was sie vorhin
angesprochen haben dass putin sagt ich
versetze die russischen atomstreitkräfte
in alarmbereitschaft das zielt auf
unsere psyche wir deutschen aber alle
europäer natürlich alle menschen haben
angst vor einem atomkrieg aber wir ganz
besonders der putin sagt ja letzten
endes hört man wenn nicht das einnehme
wenn ich das baltikum abschneiden und
die baltischen staaten auch wieder ins
russische reich sagt bloß keinen
gegenangriff ich habe meine
atomstreitkräfte bereits in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt das ist
sozusagen die strategische politische
drohung kommt bloß nicht auf die idee
wenn ich tatsächlich das baltikum
angreife das nur weil die nato stärker
ist ihr euch erlauben könnte das
zurückzuerobern und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir sehr sehr schnell
handeln dass die schnelle eingreiftruppe
der nato sehr schnell in diese drei
staaten geht und vor allem die umgebung
dieses sowie korridors der strategisch
die entscheidende bedeutung hat dort
muss verstärkt werden das haben glaube
ich alle verstanden ist in deutschland
nicht laut diskutiert weil man ja den
menschen auch nicht zu viel angst machen
möchte was ich verstehe aber ich wollte
es trotzdem mal erklären es geht
natürlich auch um angst bei diesem werk
auf was wir an er bitte andere gucke ich
würde dann wir haben in dieser
auflistung
erschreckenden auflistung ich bin davor
mit den einschätzungen aber wir haben
moldau moldawien vergessen und das ist
ein land das meines erachtens nach
zurzeit viel in einer viel größeren
gefahr potenziellen liegt zwischen
rumänien und der ukraine geschützte bald
gekommen genau es ist nämlich
es wird findet sich zwischen der queen
und rumänien ein teil davon ist
separatisten gebiet ein teil davon ist
auf diesem separatisten gebiet ist schon
mit russischen toten bestückt und das
was wir sehen und der jetzigen
militärischen operation ist ja der
vorstoß von süden um
von den plänen wurde früher schon viel
berichtet die wurden nicht irgendwie
genügend zur kenntnis genommen dass
moskau versucht eventuell einen
landkorridor von russischem territorium
von der ost ukraine 1 an die kunden zu
schaffen und dann würde man versuchen
eventuell einen weiteren landkorridor
über odessa zu den separatisten gebieten
ins transnistrien und da wäre es ein
leichtes ein kleines
absolut wehrlos land wie moldova mit
einzunehmen wenn man schon gegen die
ukraine kämpft dann kann man auch schon
mal darüber mit dandys auch nicht nato
kopiert nicht dort die nato nicht sein
können aber da zeigt sich auch
tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen teil der
lok internet teilte putin schon logik
eben auch in südosteuropa und insgesamt
in
dem osteuropäischen raum in den letzten
20 30 20 jahren vor allem nämlich es
geht ja nicht nur um die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit oder wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeit von staaten sondern auch um
die aufrechterhaltung von de facto
regime wie eben transnistrien wie in
südossetien und abchasien auf dem
kaukasus wigrim oder vor hindu hans gut
und jetzt bevor es jetzt natürlich die
lage eskaliert ist weil diese de facto
regime das sind das sind die orte aus
unglaublich gerückt autoritär regiert
natürlich international nicht anerkannt
aber da sind die westlichen flanken von
putins einfluss in der region aus der
wirklich mal gefahr ausgehen kann das
ist genau das was jetzt gerade passiert
es gibt ja unterschiedliche meldungen
man hört ja jetzt im laufe des
nachmittags möglicherweise gibt es doch
verhandlungen das ist jetzt aus
verschiedenen quellen gemeldet worden
ob kann man jetzt im moment nicht
verifizieren möglicherweise sind es muss
da müssen wir abwarten er berlinert
bündeln wir haben jetzt ja häufiger
schon das thema atomwaffen hier als
stichwort gehabt wenn es um den atomaren
schutzschirm gegen eine atomare
bedrohung russlands geht dann sind die
amerikaner da ganz wichtig sind
eigentlich die einzigen die über europa
einen atomaren schutzschirm spannen
können wenn das weiter eskaliert und
inzwischen braucht man putin ja alles zu
ist zum zweiten mal eine drohung mit
atomwaffen bei einem atomwaffen einsatz
innerhalb weniger tage wie wird denn das
in den usa aufgenommen weil dann sind
die usa ja nicht nur sozusagen gruppen
unterstützer und helfen in europa aus
sondern dann sind sie eigentlich an
vorderster front in einem konflikt
zu beraten hat sich noch nicht gezielt
dazu geäußert aber man kann davon
ausgehen dass er da tatsächlich eben im
wort steht er ist der transatlantiker er
ist derjenige der sehr viel wert legt
auf eine ganz enge zusammenarbeit wieder
mit den westlichen verbündeten was man
auch darin sehen kann wie beispielloser
geheimdienstinformationen diesmal ja
offen gelegt hat und ich denke das ist
jetzt erst mal weiter die strategie man
hofft erstmal das abschreckung
funktioniert indem man die ostflanke
stärkt man wird sicherlich weiter auf
diese geheimdienstinformationen setzen
die auch wirklich wichtig waren diesmal
weil wir ja nachhinein gesehen haben wie
richtig die amerikaner diesmal mit
diesen informationen lagen und das hat
ja immerhin auch geholfen dass putin
keine überraschungseffekte erzielen
konnte und es hat auch sehr geholfen um
eben die die westlichen verbündeten zu
einen und um da einiges vorbereiten zu
können sanktionen der gemeinsame kurs
also da ist schon viel passiert ich
setze darauf dass genau das auch weiter
versucht wird da präventiv sehr stark zu
denken
und trotz allem hofft man natürlich hier
dass es nicht zu diesem dieser
endgültigen entscheidungen kommt
gleichzeitig ist man sich sehr bewusst
dass die usa unter beobachtung steht und
auch stärke zeigen muss denn es gibt ja
auch andere staaten china der iran und
hier wird auch immer wieder ein
bewusstsein dafür geschaffen aldi
schauen geradezu und schauen sind die
amerikaner stark sind sie schwach und
dann 242 dann auch womöglich ihre
grenzen auszutesten
coco wir haben ja gerade vor der sendung
gesehen dass wladimir putin jetzt
angekündigt hat die raketen einheiten
die atomar bestückten raketen truppen in
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen das waren
ja offenbar auch die beiden
kommandierten generale die da im bild
waren läuft putin uhr oder steckt da
mehr dahinter
die frage ist dann gibt es überhaupt
noch jemanden der ihnen möglicherweise
stoppen könnte
das ist die große frage auf die niemand
antworten kann und das macht ja die
situation so brenzlig aber
ich würde es nicht unbedingt als zeichen
der stärke
interpretieren dass putin nach vier
tagen
weniger als vier tagen der
militäroperationen wie er sich ausdrückt
also des krieges in der ukraine
zuerst tschetschenische trocken also der
aufgabe das des tschetschenischen
präsidenten
die bekannt und berüchtigt ist für ihre
grausamkeit und für häuserkampf
einsetzen lässt in kiew und zweitens
dass er erneut mit atomwaffen droht ich
würde das eventuell auch als eine art
schwäche
interpretieren es läuft anscheinend
militärisch nicht so wie man sich das in
moskau vorgestellt hat trotzdem will ich
das nicht verharmlosen wir wissen nicht
wir sind alle überrascht worden
wozu putin dann doch fähig ist nicht
rational sondern rational zu handeln das
ist ja das problem
er handelte er jetzt in den letzten
tagen irrational deswegen
ja aber es ist das einzige was hier
große hoffnungen macht ist putin scheint
sich selbst und seinen komfort und seine
gesundheit so zu schätzen dass er kaum
darauf verdichtet ist in einem bunker in
einem radioaktiv zerstörten moskau sein
leben zu ende zu leben das macht mir
eine gewisse hoffnung ein rationaler am
auslöseknopf für den atomschlag
was wie ist das einzuschätzen dieses es
ist ja denn dem westen schon vor einigen
tagen die knochen gefahren als er das
zwar nicht offen angekündigt gehört sie
werden eine gegenreaktion wie noch nie
in ihrer geschichte erleben das hat man
ja dann tatsächlich auf einen atomwaffen
einsatz bezieht ja aber diese
ankündigung solange es verbale
ankündigen sondern die zielen ja vor
allem auf unsere psyche putin das fest
davon überzeugt dass westliche
gesellschaften insbesondere die deutsche
gesellschaft so schwach sind sich so
dekadent sind dass sie ja letzten endes
kann nicht mehr bereit sind sich zu
verteidigen und das ist sozusagen eine
androhung wie ich versuchte vor ihm zu
erklären falls ich das baltikum oberer
probiert das bloß nicht aus dass zurück
zur urbanen das ist ja eigentlich unsere
die nato sicherheitsgarantie man weiß
dass man das baltikum nicht leicht
verteidigen kann die drohung ist immer
die nato ist aber so sehr russland
überlegen dass man truppen heranführen
kann zurückerobern kann und dagegen
zielt das eigentlich es ist eigentlich
jetzt für mich eine
herzliche es auch psychologisch
menschlich sehr sehr schwierig darüber
zu spekulieren ob wir jetzt mit einem
atomwaffen einsatz zu rechnen haben oder
nicht aber wir sollten uns alle klar
machen das ist nicht die entscheidung
eines mannes es ist auch nicht die
entscheidung eines mannes in washington
denn zur trump zeit als manche leute
dachten der tramp könnte spinnen da hat
das militär ja klar gesagt die höchste
generalität rechtswidrige befehle werden
sie nicht befolgen das wird auch immer
getan und ich hoffe ich hoffe das müssen
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder eher
andere goc frank aber ich hoffe doch
auch dass es unter der russischen
generalität und dem russischen der
russischen armee nicht nur treue
gefolgsleute von putin gibt die egal was
er befiehlt das einfach umsetzen sondern
dass das verantwortungsbewusste menschen
sind die familien haben die wollen dass
sie und ihre familien überleben und herr
gehofft hatte dass wir schon ein
bisschen angedeutet als er sagte putin
kann sich auf diese befehls treue gar
nicht so sehr verlassen deswegen holt er
ja die schlägertrupps sag ich jetzt mal
aus tschetschenien damit die den
häuserkampf führen weil er nicht sicher
ist dass normale russische soldaten die
verbrecherischen befehle am ende
wirklich ausführen
ich glaube das ist tatsächlich mal diese
heutige reaktion ist eher ein zeichen
dass putin sich absolut verrechnet hat
es davon ausgegangen dass ja sehr
schnell in die ukraine einmarschiert und
auch die series gestürzt und das dass
das der start sehr schnell zu einem
spezialisten stadt gemacht wird
zusammenbricht dass die verteidigung
einfach nicht funktioniert und dass der
westen nicht tut es mit es kann sein
dass er selber an eigene lügen geglaubt
hat das ist eine option und das was wir
heute von ihm gehört haben es bestätigt
er so die these so das ist alles es
läuft alles nicht nach plan die
ukrainische verteidigung hält sie lenski
ist nach wie vor in der ukraine und noch
schlimmer für putin wie die von waffen
und das ist tatsächlich diese
zeitenwende und da sieht man sehr
deutlich dass all diese wirtschaftliche
connections aldi putin versteher hier in
deutschland und in aber natürlich auch
anderen europäischen ländern dass diese
diese taktik nicht aufgegangen ist und
das ist enorm wichtig und deswegen würde
ich heute vielleicht weniger von
atomwaffen sprechen sondern tatsächlich
sprechen darüber wie wir als europäische
gemeinschaft nato eu europarat alle
zusammenhalten können
diese diesen krieg so schnell wie
möglich zu ende zu bringen und
tatsächlich auch wieder für den frieden
in der ukraine in der gesamten ukraine
also schließen sich ja voraus andrej
kurkow das ist sozusagen die erweiterung
der frage die küste von marschall gerade
gestellt hat dass es in der russischen
militäradministration vernunft
gesteuerte generelle gibt es jetzt für
den konventionellen einsatz in der
ukraine sei es für einen möglichen
atomaren
kann man darauf rechnen dass es eine
ähnliche situation gibt wie in
washington da wäre man plant auch in den
arm gefallen
also ich würde nicht da mich so sehr
darauf verlassen und wir haben ja bei
der show bei der fernsehshow als botin
den sicherheitsrat aufmarschieren ließ
um sozusagen seine
ukraine fantasien freien lauf zu geben
und praktisch den marschbefehl absegnen
zu lassen die haben wir gesehen wie er
seinen auslandsgeheimdienst stadt nieder
gemacht hat das ist die ral gegangenen
denn in den sozialen medien
das zeugt davon dass selbst durch ein
einflussreicher will man vermuten man
ein kollege von putin also ein
auslands geheimdienst chef vor ihm
zittern buchstäblich ja und damit wie an
einem hausboot deswegen würde ich
ich habe diese hoffnung auch aber ich
würde sie nicht zu hoch hängen
allerdings ist vor diesem vor diesen
ganzen ereignissen einer erklärung
ehemaliger russische militärs und zwar
aus einer ganz rechten ecke und
nationalistisch geprägte ganz eindeutig
er sozusagen das putin lektorat die vor
einem krieg gewarnt hatten sie hatten
ihre eigenen argumentation sie sagen
aber auch dass das ist eine tragödie
führen könnte also in der in unter
militärs gibt es diese stimmung ob es
waren zumindest die stimmen der
ehemaligen militärs in gewalt sind noch
verbindungen oder einfluss auf die
aktiven militärs haben das kann ich
nicht beurteilen berliner bündeln wir
sind jetzt gerade in der abteilung
schreckensszenarien was bedeutet das
eigentlich für den konflikt in europa
der sicherlich noch länger dauern wird
den konflikt insgesamt diesen krieg und
möglicherweise andere kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen von der von
russland verursacht wenn jetzt bei den
kongresswahlen im herbst die
republikaner möglicherweise auch viele
drum pisten in senat und
repräsentantenhaus die mehrheit
erreichen das könnte ja durchaus sein
wenn
2024 trump oder ein tramp ist wieder us
präsident wird was bedeutet das konkret
was würde das konkret für den westen in
diesem konflikt bedeuten
ja das bedeutet erstmal eine deutlich
schwierigere lage also wenn beiden jetzt
seine gestaltungsmacht verliert im
kongress in dem er eben die mehrheit im
kongress verliert dann ist er natürlich
schon mal gelähmt und kann nicht so
handeln wie es seinen seinen werten
seinen überzeugungen entspricht
natürlich immer bei der muss sich
natürlich mit dem kongress abstimmen und
egal wer nach beiden kommt so weit ist
so ein überzeugter transatlantiker des
alten schlags also selbst bei an
demokraten müsste man ein fragezeichen
dran machen ob da jemand ähnlich in
richtung europa denkt oder nicht doch
vielleicht in richtung von anderen
herausforderungen denkt was jetzt die
tram pisten angeht oder eben tatsächlich
die republik keiner muss man sich darauf
einstellen dass die im zweifelsfall sehr
stark auch nochmal auf innenpolitik
gehen da liegt gerade auch sehr sehr
viel unzufriedenheit dass wenn wir uns
jetzt beiden sum bestimmung
zustimmungswerte anschauen sind derzeit
nur 33 prozent zufrieden auch mit seiner
ukraine politik also selbst obwohl er ja
eigentlich der gestandene außenpolitiker
ist mit dem man ja auch damals damit hat
er geworben bei seiner wiederwahl ist es
gerade nichts was ihn zustimmung
einträgt und so muss man sich wirklich
darauf einstellen dass wenn er da seine
seine kongressmehrheit verliert dass wir
dann aus den usa deutlich mehr
stillstand und deutlich mehr zu sehen so
erwarten haben marshall da sind zum teil
haarsträubende perspektiven was die
sicherheit in westeuropa in den
westeuropäischen nato staaten angeht
es gibt jetzt ja überlegungen zu sagen
auf die usa ist nicht immer verlass dass
sie diesen atomaren schutzschirm
wirklich aufspannen stichwort war ein
2024 die französische atommacht force de
frappe genannt ist wie zu schwach gegen
die russiche also müsste man sich
überlegen ob die europäische union
insgesamt damit eben auch deutschland
nicht selbst zu einer atommacht wird
also dass sich auch bundeswehr und
andere europäische
armeen mit atomwaffen versehen um auch
glaubhaft gegenüber russland
abschreckung zu betreiben ist das eine
perspektive und die wir nicht herum
kommen jetzt mal unabhängig davon dass
das natürlich zu massiven politischen
konflikten auch in deutschland führt
also ich hör einer generation an für die
das sehr sehr schwer vorstellbar ist
dass deutschland sich atomar bewaffnet
ich bin noch nicht sicher dass das der
klügste investition wäre was unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit und was unsere
abschreckungsfähigkeit betrifft ich
würde aus dem was frau bunten gesagt hat
er auch versuchen eine positive
schlussfolgerung zu ziehen
ob amerika bereit ist das bündnis mit
europa wieder zu stärken hängt ja nicht
nur davon ab wie er im weißen haus sitzt
und wer die mehrheiten im senat und im
repräsentantenhaus hat es hängt vor
allem erstmal von uns ab wenn wir nicht
weiter dieser stimmung futter geben auch
die europäer die sind ja nur
trittbrettfahrer die verlassen sich auf
uns wir amerikaner sollen mal wieder die
die kohlen aus dem feuer holen und so
weiter dann ist das schlecht für uns
aber wenn wir sagen wenn diesmal nicht
nur gesagt wird was ihr angela merkel
nach der wahl kramp und einem bierzelt
gesagt hat wir sind jetzt in einer
situation wo wir uns nicht mehr zu 100
prozent auf amerika verlassen können sie
hat aber nichts getan angela merkel oder
wenig getan unter angela merkel das ist
jetzt nun schon jahre her ist ja nun
nicht der verteidigungsetat signifikant
erhöht worden wenn das was heute im
bundestag passiert ist wenn das nun
wirklich passiert dann werden wir ja
auch als verbündete für die usa
wesentlich interessanter und amerika hat
keine besseren verbündeten als die
demokratien in aller welt dh die
demokratien hier in europa inklusive der
neuen demokratien polen tschechien
slowakei weiter und die demokratien in
asien also japan
australien/neuseeland man kann dann
südkorea man kann überlegen wie weit das
auch auf indien zutrifft das leider eine
etwas nationalistische regierung hat
aber wenn dieses bewusstsein einsetzt
wir sind eigentlich die stärkeren wir
demokratien weltweit aber wir müssen ein
verlässliches bündnis nicht nur einen
schönen wetter bündnis schließen wir
müssen handlungsfähig sein wenn sich das
jetzt endlich durchsetzt und nachhaltig
im bewusstsein fest setzt dann glaube
ich haben wir ganz gute chancen und
müssen nicht angstvoll in die zukunft
sein sondern kann mit etwas zuversicht
in die zukunft sehen und dass deswegen
sei nochmal das war heute ein guter tag
im bundestag gerade weil es von einer
rot grün gelben regierung so
vorangetrieben wurde und nicht von einer
konservativen regierung gegen widerstand
oder protest links der mitte aber mit
der unterstützung des der
christdemokraten mit der unterstützung
natürlich ist ein sehr breites bündnis
das bereit ist jetzt endlich spät aber
endlich diese konsequenzen zu ziehen und
das was glaube ich noch mal wichtig ist
letzter punkt ist dass der krieg
garniert wird und dass wir nicht nur uns
auf das thema atomare abschreckung
konzentrieren sollen das was heute auch
im bundestag gesagt worden ist auf die
cyber abwehr die resilienz er wirklich
mal die widerstandsfähigkeit bei die
kommt ja also der krieg wird nicht nur
mit waffen und nicht mit panzern geführt
heutzutage und das muss ganz ganz klar
sein und darauf müssen wir alle in
europa praktisch lahmlegen sensibler
digitale infrastruktur fast ein eigenes
thema für eine sendung aber eben auch
diese hybride kriegsführung müssen wir
ja fürchten agof
ich wollte einen gedanken jetzt beim
zuhören wir
spekulieren wiesbaden im november
ergehen wird ich glaube das thema können
wir übermorgen diskutieren zurzeit ist
bei einem amt und wir haben einen krieg
und ich glaube die wichtigen
entscheidungen in diesem krieg in der
ukraine werden in der nächsten oder in
den nächsten zwei drei wochen fallen
also die wahlen im november das ist
zukunftsmusik und wie sich dann die
verteidigung europas gestalten wird und
wie
tief das bündnis atlantische bündnis
dann unter einer republikanischen
mehrheit wie auch immer sein wird dass
es zurzeit ein äußerst theoretisches
thema das vorhin als 60 der ukraine als
prämisse gesagt es geht um sechs bin
immer noch da sein
ja aber die heiße phase das des krieges
sie wird die nächsten tage oder nächsten
wochen und dann wird sich irgendwie das
entweder wird putin siegen oder er wird
scheitern
oder man wird einfach verhandlungsweg
finden und sie
widerstandsfähiger die ukraine ist desto
schneller wird sich wohl ein
verhandlungsweg anbahnen frau bin ich
würde gerne mal darauf dass eingehen was
christoph von marschall gerade skizziert
hat das offenbar jetzt in deutschland
viele aufgewacht sind dass sie etwas für
die verteidigung tun müssen für die
eigene verteidigung eine
effektive abschreckung die auch wirklich
als solche wirkt auch viel mehr für die
militärische rüstung um sich gegen
mögliche
feindliche nachbarn zu rüsten das ist ja
im prinzip eine fortschreibung der
forderungen die donald trump während
seiner amtszeit an die europäer
besonders die deutschen gerichtet hat
das heißt das würde ja auch eine
strategie sein die in den usa
wahrscheinlich sehr positiv aufgenommen
werden würde hätte das auch dann
auswirkungen auf das verhältnis auf die
sich der usa auf ihre europäischen nato
partner auf
jeden fall also das ist tatsächlich da
stimme ich christoph von marschall zu
das ist tatsächlich der punkt der hier
gefordert wird von den amerikanern
übrigens auch nicht nur von tram barack
obama hat schon gesagt die deutschen
müssen wir investieren in ihre
verteidigung trump hat es nur besonders
kompromisslos vorgetragen die forderung
ist die ganze zeit schon die gleiche der
ton ist nur wieder ein anderer der ist
gerade wieder freundschaftlicher aber es
ist tatsächlich so dass deutschland hier
gesehen wird in den usa als die
mächtigsten wirtschaftsnationen
in europa die aber einfach ihrer
politischen bedeutung nicht gerecht wird
und die eben nicht bereit ist sich aus
dieser komfortzone heraus zu bewegen und
ja es ist definitiv so dass das ja
eigentlich erwartet wird und dass wir
jetzt mit beiden und blinken noch zwei
politiker im weißen haus an die sehr
sehr freundlichen ton immer an den tag
legen auch beim letzten kanzler besuch
teilweise olaf scholz beigesprungen sind
immer wieder aber davon wird man
dauerhaft nicht ausgehen können und
entsprechend werden die deutschen wenn
sie weiter partner sein sollen aus
amerikanischer sicht definitiv mehr über
ihren schatten springen müssen es ist
nicht auszuschließen dass putin zum ziel
kommt und die ukraine in den nächsten
tagen oder wochen militärisch besiegt
was würde die eu wäre die unmittelbare
folge für europa und für die natur
also ich fürchte das wird so sein
natürlich was herr prokop wir uns hier
völlig zurecht vorgetragen hat dass es
für putin nicht so gut läuft wie er
geplant hat aber einfach die die
kraftverhältnisse die sind einfach so
dass die ukraine mittel und langfristig
keine wirkliche chance hat sich gegen
die übermächtige macht zu behaupten sie
fragen was das dann für uns bedeutet ja
reden wir auch mal über
kraftverhältnisse
die europäische union ist alleine
bereits ohne amerika wirtschaftlich
sieben bis acht mal so stark wie
russland gemeinsam mit den vereinigten
staaten sind wir ungefähr 15 16 mal
stärker und das müssen wir uns mal klar
machen was das für eine absurde
situation ist das ein bündnis das diese
enormen ökonomischen und auch
wissenschaftlichen ressourcen hat angst
vor diesem kleinen wirtschaftlich
kleinen russland das in drei prozent der
weltwirtschaft ja und hier sind
annähernd 45 prozent warum haben wir
angst vor denen und er nicht angst vor
uns das heißt doch nur dass wir etwas
falsch organisiert haben dass wir
offenbar unsere enormen ressourcen nicht
so umsetzen in verteidigungsfähigkeit in
ökonomische überlegenheit da sind wir
ganz gut in politische überlegenheit und
lässt das ist die konsequenz wir müssen
uns überlegen was müssen wir in unserer
aufstellung ändern an unserem verhalten
damit unsere enorme unsere enormen
ressourcen auch zum tragen kommen wenn
es um solche entscheidenden fragen wie
krieg oder frieden geht das ist auch
heute den schuss gehört das kann ich
dann auch nur noch mal wiederholen ich
habe die hoffnung ich habe nach dieser
bundestagsdebatte die hoffnung nach den
erklärungen des kanzlers des grünen
wirtschaftsministers das geld ein finanz
des fdp finanzminister ich habe wirklich
die hoffnung dass wir diesmal wirklich
den schuss gehört haben ich sage aber
gleich nochmal dazu auch nach den
balkankriegen die europa nicht beenden
konnte ohne die hilfe der usa haben wir
gesagt wir haben den schuss gehört und
jetzt haben daraus gelernt jetzt werden
wir was tun aus 2014 überfall auf die
krim und die ost ukraine haben wir auch
versprochen wir haben den schuss gehört
jetzt wird sich was ändern es hat sich
aber nicht genug geändert und deswegen
müssen wir das in den nächsten tagen und
wochen und monaten beobachten ob das
hoffentlich nicht nur lippenbekenntnisse
waren sondern das ist diesmal nachhaltig
ist wir können zuversichtlich sein wenn
wir diesen um ressourcen die wir haben
in deutschland in europa und im
transatlantischen verhältnis nutzen und
erst recht in asien mit den dortigen
demokratie wir sind nicht verloren das
lassen wir jetzt hier so stehen denn wir
sind am ende dieser sendung ganz
bestimmt aber nicht am ende dieses
themas themas ich bedanke mich bei
veronika priesmeier ich bedanke mich bei
christoph von marschall zugeschaltet aus
washington verena bünten und andrej
kurkow von der deutschen welle mit
zuschauer dieses thema das wird uns
leider noch lange beschäftigen phoenix
natürlich auch in den nächsten tagen
nahezu rund um die uhr es bleibt
spannend auch in unserem programm
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]